these are the first pictures of the us
operation to kill the leader of isil
the short declassified footage initially
shows u.s troops moving towards the
compound in northern syria
where they attract abu bakr al-baghdadi
those who came out of the building were
checked for weapons and explosives
and moved away from the immediate area
u.s forces detained and later released
the non-combatants
the group was treated humanely at all
times and included 11 children
the assault force drew the attention of
fighters in the area they're not thought
to be iso linked
but when they fired on us aircraft
involved in the operation
they were killed inside the compound
isil fighters staged the last stand
five isis members inside the compound
presented a threat to the force
they did not respond to commands in
arabic to surrender and they continued
to threaten the force
they were then engaged by the raid force
and killed there were four women and one
man
the general confirmed baghdadi took two
of his children into the tunnel when he
tried to escape the assault force not
three
as originally reported there he
detonated his suicide vest killing
himself
and the children after baghdadi's
murder-suicide
our assault force cleared significant
debris from the tunnel
and secured baghdadi's remains through
dni identity confirmation
which were flown with the assault
assault force back to the staging base
he could not confirm president trump's
assertion that the leader of isil died
screaming
crying and whimpering dna confirmed his
identity
the operation on the ground took around
two hours phones and computers were
removed from the compound before it was
raised to the ground by american
missiles
they don't want the area to become a
shrine when donald trump announced the
death of baghdadi it was hailed as a
significant moment in the fight against
isil
and while the general believes it may
disrupt the organization
he's warned there could be retaliatory
attacks
he says the group won't disappear
warning isil is an ideology
and you can't kill an ideology alan
fisher al jazeera washington